Victoria Victoria Madeleine Sharpe do
you swear by Almighty God do swear by
Almighty God which I will be faithful
that I will be faithful and bear true
allegiance and bear true allegiance
Majesty Queen Elizabeth the second to
Her Majesty Queen Elizabeth the second
and successors according to law her
heirs and successors according to law
why I Victoria Madeleine Sharpe do swear
by Almighty God do swear by Almighty God
that I will well and truly serve that I
will well and truly serve of sovereign
lady Queen Elizabeth the second our
sovereign lady Queen Elizabeth the
second in the office of president of the
Queen's Bench division in the office of
president of the Queen's Bench division
and I will do right to all manner of
people and I will do right to all manner
of people after the laws and usages of
this realm after the laws and usages of
this realm without fear or favour
without fear or favour affection or
ill-will affection or ill-will
mr. Atkins on Friday we gathered to bid
farewell - sabrine Leverson as president
of the Queen's Bench division this
afternoon we celebrate Dame Victoria
sharps appointment as his successor as
we receive her oaths of office now Dame
victoria was educated in North London
and then at Bristol University where she
read law she had determined on a career
in the law indeed as a barrister from a
very early age
it was certainly apparent by the time
she was about 12
her father was then working in the
United States and as any of you who had
expatriate parents will remember
correspondence was conducted via flimsy
blue airmail letters Dame victoria
retains a letter from her father
encouraging her in her ambition he
commented on her eloquence something we
all recognized and added one day you
might become a High Court judge that was
a remarkable piece of foresight given
that at the time there was only one
woman High Court judge mrs. Justice
Elizabeth Lane Dame Victoria herself
tells me that there was an element of
stubbornness in her choice she well knew
even as an early teenager that the world
of law was one of the most difficult in
which women could prosper and she was
damn well going to show everyone that
she could conquer it
rising to challenges has been a hallmark
of her career Dame victoria was called
to the bar by the Inner Temple in 1979
and took silk in 2001 she became a bench
of her in in 2009 our new president's
practice was in defamation and media law
she was pupil to Richard Rampton at one
brick court and remained as a tenant
from where she practiced and sit until
she became a judge of the Queen's Bench
division in 2009 and what a remarkable
practice it was we will hear more of
that I'm sure from Lord Gagne in a few
minutes but whether as a junior or in
silk game Victoria was involved in many
of the most high-profile cases
in the field when asked for the times
lawyer of the week feature in 2007 what
her worst day as a lawyer had been she
answered no doubt rather
matter-of-factly although perhaps with
an impish grin getting run over on the
pedestrian crossing outside the Royal
Courts of Justice she added that she was
in the middle of a long-running libel
action that was lured ording tynin
Tolstoy and then continued but luckily
it was a Friday lunchtime so I was able
to return on Monday in plaster how many
I wonder would have done that one of my
personal pleasures in welcoming Dame
Victoria today is that our judicial
lives have run pretty well in parallel
we both became assistant recorders in
1998 and attended the training course
private presided over by the then mr.
justice judge that was a as hard a four
days work as we have ever endured
in 2008 Dame Victoria became a deputy
High Court judge before joining the
Queen's Bench division in 2009 I was
then delighted to learn that Dame
Victoria was to join me as a presiding
judge on the Western circuit at the
beginning of 2013 and when she took up
the post she enthusiastically became
involved in all the affairs of the
circuit now it's not unheard of for
presiding judges to bail out before the
end of their four-year term because the
court of appeal has beckoned
but Dame Victoria confessed to me only
after a few months in office that many
by encouraging her to apply to the Court
of Appeal which was then in need of some
media experience as she was of course
immediately appointed in October 2013
and that was after only four years in
the High Court we lost her from the
Western circuit to the Court of Appeal
because she combines legal skills with
those of organization and leadership
which are in great demand she threw
herself into many activities not least
reviewing and revising welfare
arrangements for judges no one could
have been surprised when in 2016 she was
appointed vice-president of the Queen's
Bench division a member of the judicial
executive board and of the judges
Council in that role she worked closely
with her predecessor in dealing with the
vast range of responsibilities that
attached to the Queen's Bench division
not only crime both on circuit and in
the Court of Appeal Criminal Division
and a wide range of civil cases but also
the Commercial Court the Admiralty court
the technology and construction court
the Administrative Court and the Queen's
Bench masters overall responsibility for
all those areas now Falls to our new
president along with much criminal
policy work and continued involvement in
all issues that affect the judiciary all
who've worked with Dame Victoria can
attest to her calm and insightful
contributions to debate and her
remarkable capacity for hard work I do
wonder however whether an early display
of stubbornness and sense of humor when
a pupil might have brought the promising
career to an end the early 80s was a
time when many people smoked at work the
media world were big smokers and so ii
was dame victoria's pupil master she
detested conducting business in the fog
of multiple smokers and not least
because her pupil master smoked
particularly filthy french cigarettes
I've been informed by a former member of
her chambers possibly reliably that over
lunch one day she emptied a firework of
its gunpowder and stuffed a little into
the end of each sheet an and then a wait
awaited events in conference mister
Rampton calmly took a cigarette to show
solidarity with his media friends he lit
it and it exploded in his face the room
erupted in laughter but the pupil was
seen to be studying her notebook with
special intensity while trying to stifle
giggles in those chambers it went down
as the only recorded example of a pupil
trying to assassinate a pupil master
whether she was taken on as a tenant
because of or in spite of this incident
remains a mystery now I I I've observed
that before that in advance of welcoming
a judge publicly to any new role I have
a quick look at the internet for
inspiration Dame victoria seems to
maintain an iron grip on what
information is available publicly about
her her who's who entry is Spartan a
Wikipedia profile short there are judges
about whom I receive emails from their
friends often including very interesting
but quite unusable material at least in
a public forum yet in Dane Victoria's
case she seems to have maintained a
discipline which would be the envy of
any Chief Whip there's nothing but
having been given the account of her
incendiary character if I can call it
that my attention lighted upon an
internet entry which said simply FBI
video shows Victoria Sharpe surrendering
to the police for a moment I did wonder
whether the two things might be
connected but I'm unable to make a
positive identification from the
accompanying video indeed I'm confident
it's not our Victoria Sharpe the suspect
is wearing terrible shoes and tracksuit
bottoms Dame Victoria has taken on one
of the biggest jobs in the law
understandably her appointment was
greeted with universal approbation the
role requires energy leadership and
vision all of which Dame Victoria has in
abundance in Dame Victoria sharp we have
a president of the Queen's Bench
division superbly qualified to discharge
all the obligations of her office and
who will bring wisdom insight and if I
may say so a sense of fun to her new
role we congratulate her on her
appointment and wish her well - she
embarks on the next stage of her most
remarkable career my lord
I feel that I'm becoming a bit of an all
tend to these valedictory
having welcomed surround Rue McFarland
having said farewell to Sir David Frost
get and Sabrina s'en only last Friday
but I was not sure quite what to expect
today in welcoming the new president of
the Queen's Bench division as you will
remember I attended the Commonwealth Law
conference in April in Zambia as did you
and Lady Justice Sharpe
whose appointment to succeed Sir Brian
had just been announced the conference
was opened by the Zambian president who
arrived how should I put it
diplomatically somewhat after the
published start time accompanied by many
security guards and much relating I
wondered if it may have given our
soon-to-be president any ideas
and so I cleared the entire evening from
my diary I put some earplugs in my
pocket the security contingent that has
preceded her today is of a similar size
to those who accompanied the president
but I'm relieved to be able to tell you
my lord so far they have been somewhat
quieter now I appreciate that what goes
on on tour
or generally stays on tour but there is
one story that needs mentioning the
conference was held in the very pleasant
but quite functional of Varney hotel
close to the Victoria Falls a short
distance away was the vastly superior
Victoria Falls Hotel something of a
throwback to the colonial days I visited
it and could only just about afford to
share a beer with the head of the bar
councils international team you my Lord
and I stayed in the Avani hotel Lady
Justice Sharpe was upgraded to the
Victoria Falls Hotel whether there is
any truth in the rumor that when asked
for her name she replied president sharp
I simply do not know now so far I have
not had the good fortune of appearing in
front of the president so who have not
had the opportunity of calling her your
honor or messing up in any other
spectacular way as I did with her
predecessor yet I did however sit as a
recorder in Warwick Crown Court some
years ago when she then was mrs. justice
Sharpe was there the resident judge is
on a judge Richard Griffiths Joan
'deputy my friend the late is on a judge
Alan Parker to hold the fort I arrived
in the judicial dining room at lunch
time to find Alan in the state of high
anxiety where should he put the High
Court judge at the judicial table
what seating plan should there be how
should he address her these are just
some of the questions that poured out
from him I tried to calm him telling him
not to worry
they were only likely to be Alan myself
and possibly Her Majesty's coroner at
lunch so there wasn't too much of a
seating plan to be sorted out and there
was in any event no guarantee given how
hard we know she works that she would be
joining us he relaxed momentarily and we
sat down to start lunch
if sooner had we sat down and the mrs.
justice Sharpe entered the dining room
Alan bolted upright drawing himself up
to his full five foot six inches on
tiptoe before bearing so low he nearly
bang his head on the floor myself and
her majesty's coroner felt obliged to do
the same well at least we stood up
mrs. justice Sharpe stood there
wide-eyed no doubt wondering what on
earth was going on and what sort of
court she had actually come to
thankfully my lady told us to sit down
and carry on with our lunch and did her
best to put Alan at his ease no easy
task but she managed it with aplomb well
Lord I'm delighted to be able to welcome
the new president of the Queen's Bench
division although of all of the people
I've had to do valedictory roots for
either as chair of the bar or former
leader of the midland circuit she as you
have already mentioned is proving to be
one of the most difficult who's who
entry must be one of the shortest in the
book and as you've already pointed out
lists no interests although I understand
she has a huge interest in and is a
discerning critic of the arts and
particularly music and we will not be
hearing any who are the Beatles or even
storms the questions
when she is presiding a Wikipedia entry
though may need a little more work on it
as it suggests she took silk in 1986 at
only 7 years call
it's even earlier than your justice boss
[Laughter]
and that she was on the High Court bench
from 1993 to 2000 what she did between
2000 and her elevation to the Court of
Appeal in 2013 is anybody's guess my
lady did those serve as you've mentioned
for a short period as presider on the
Western circuit I'm told by a former
leader of the circuit that in one case
over which she presided there had to be
a site visit to a pretty rough district
in Bristol during the course of which a
rather large and not entirely friendly
crowd gathered mrs. Justice sharps
brooch and necklace worn discreetly were
glinting noticeably in the sunlight and
the Western Circuit leader former chair
of the bar quite a big chap was
decidedly nervous the rather smaller
High Court judge though remained as cool
as a cucumber whether that was because
she was familiar with the area from her
days at Bristol University I have been
unable to discover my lord I understand
that the president decided that the
career at the bar was for her having
spent much of her childhood defending
her naughty brother in front of their
parental court and we have a lot to
thank him for she had a stellar career
at the Defamation bar which we'll hear
more from Lord Garnier shortly a short
four year tenure on the High Court bench
was a great success
before her elevation to the Court of
Appeal in 2013 and it is no surprise to
any of us at the bar that she has been
chosen to take over from Sir Brian my
sister my spies tell me that there are
no easy rides in my lady's Court but if
you are well-prepared and your arguments
are sound you could not ask for a fairer
tribunal
one who will listen with care and has
even been known to give a nod of the
current encouragement on occasions may I
on behalf of the bar in England and
Wales wish her well in this mute new
post and may I say I'm looking forward
to working with her and the remaining
half of my turn as chair of the bar his
black holes
president my Lords ladies and gentlemen
as president of the Law Society of
England Wales and on behalf of the
solicitors profession it's a great joy
to welcome you as president of the
Queen's Bench division and we very much
look forward to working with you through
your work and the Court of Appeal the
High Court the Western circuit and at
the bar your ladyship has been involved
in many cases that have attracted the
attention of the press and the public at
large the rise in social media and other
societal changes have led to our
institutions facing heightened scrutiny
in recent years we've seen both the
judiciary and the legal profession face
stringent criticism for simply doing its
job delivering justice and upholding the
rule of law the legal profession stand
ready to play our role in explaining and
defending the PIA principles of our
justice system this must include the
need for due process and the crucial
role of our esteemed judiciary
particularly when your Lordships and
ladyship's can't do so yourselves this
solicitors profession will continue to
champion the rule of law and we have no
doubt that collaboration with your
ladyship will be part of this the rule
of law is also demonstrated through
delivering the principle of access to
justice and our justice system is facing
challenges from new technologies and
fluctuations in public spending
technology is bringing new crimes and
new forms of evidence which we must have
the skills and the resources to tackle
we've also seen several new legal tests
from technology in your ladies area of
specialism the technology also has a big
part to play in improving the way that
we deliver justice and your ladyship's
role in the Lord Chief Justice's
advisory group on artificial
intelligence
we'll seek to ensure the jurisdiction is
ready to take advantage of the
opportunities that technology will bring
the solicitor's profession will work
with you on this important project and
on a personal note I look forward to
working together in my capacity as chair
of the law tech delivery panel to face
into these challenges and to embrace the
opportunities that emerging technologies
bring to our justice system challenges
also come from the impact the reduction
in the availability of legal aid and
this has eroded access to justice for
some of the most vulnerable in our
society and led to regional disparities
and accessing legal aid it's also had a
significant impact on the sustainability
of our professions we look forward to
working with your ladyship to ensure
that we continue to have a justice
system which serves all and is admired
by the world and finally a normal issue
which is very close to my heart I really
want to commend you as the first woman
to hold this esteemed position of
president of the Queen's Bench division
well soon I hope there will be no more
thirsts for women to reach any position
in the legal profession this should not
take away from the need to celebrate
each and every time that it happens your
ladyship has always been an amazing
trailblazer and I have no doubt that you
will bring the passion and the
dedication you have bought to your legal
and your judicial careers so far to this
crucial role in challenging times
president once again mayor welcome you
to your new role
well Gagne
my lord I have noticed that a tradition
has grown up for occasions such as this
an elderly male silk on the downhill
pasture retirement it's not if not death
gets up to tell the Lord Chief Justice
that thanks to the many cases in which
he led the newly promoted or appointed
judge and the way in which he skillfully
guided him or her through the thickets
of their early practice this fortunate
man or woman is now to adorn the Court
of Appeal or the High Court bench in my
case it is true that retirement and even
death may shortly cut short my practice
at the bar although I hope not quite yet
but in the case of Dame Victoria Sharpe
we are venturing into radical territory
I have never led her in a case which may
go some way but perhaps not very far to
explain why she is sitting alongside you
as the new president of the Queen's
Bench division my lord if Dame
Victoria's family have every reason to
be pleased today so to do her other
family we have friends from her old
chains one brick cord our
congratulations to her our heartfelt it
was there not so long ago that she began
what became a stellar career at the bar
and on the bench as you have said my
lord she read law at Bristol in 2014 her
University made her an honorary Doctor
of Laws it was made clear by the orator
that Bristol had been her first choice
as an undergraduate that was if I may
say so entirely unnecessary
Victoria shop doesn't understand
expressions such as second choice or
second best call to the bar in 1979 she
joined us as a tenant in our small
specialist chambers specializing in
media law after her pupilage an eventful
pupilage as you've described with
richard Rampton and save again the story
that brings us to today
it was clear beyond any doubt that our
new tenant was a worker our clerks knew
that she could be relied on from a very
early stage know solicitor was let down
by this barrister even if the
instructions for tomorrow's case were
delivered late no judge was left
disappointed by her failure to prepare
to marshal the facts and the law or by a
confused or incoherent presentation no
leader was ever left wondering why
they'd been lumbered with a dunce for a
junior no client ever felt they had not
got their money's worth in court or on
paper no opponent failed to notice that
they faced an opponent not a patsy in
court her thoroughness was not only
legendary from her beginnings at the bar
but has underscored her professional
life as a more senior junior as a silk
and as a judge but let it not be thought
that the new president of the Queen's
Bench division is a dullard or a Drudge
never make that mistake my lord and I'm
sure you happened
it is said but this must be a lie that
when as an undergraduate Dame Victoria
went to watch a murder trial at Bristol
Crown Court the details were so gruesome
that she fainted not much phases her as
a heavily pregnant barrister appearing
before the judge in chambers in room 98
she went into labour
although the baby was good enough to
wait until she'd finished her
submissions
I suspect that both the judge and her
opponent were mightily relieved that
they did not have to act as midwives and
no doubt Emmeline is relieved that she
wasn't called Duncan Neil or Gatlin
I confessed at the outset that I'd never
led Victoria Shop I have though appeared
in cases with and against her perhaps
most notably in the libel action brought
by the late Lord Alden against Nikolai
Tolstoy over allegations that he'd been
a war criminal it was tried before Mr
Justice Michael Davis not always a
dispassionate forum and a jury in 1989
the claimant was represented by mr.
Charles gray Queen's Counsel as he then
was and a barely 33 year old miss Sharpe
led by Richard Rampton who appeared for
Tolstoy I appeared for his co-defendant
Nigel Watts it was historically
factually and legally a totally
absorbing case in which we were
concerned with just ten days of May 1945
and for me it would have been even more
absorbing had my advice and my
instructions not parted company leading
my client to sack me after a few weeks
into the very long trial but these
things happen Lord Alden was later
awarded record libel damages of 1.5
million tons it was a stressful case but
throughout my involvement in the many
months before the trial and the weeks of
it
Victoria Sharpe was supportive
collegiate and a constant source of both
encouragement and extra strong mints
time alone does not allow me to list the
cases ship hid in both as a junior and
more particularly than in silk but there
were a good many of them mostly but not
always for defendant newspapers
requiring a lot of work patience and an
ability to get on and do the job on
behalf of demanding and sometimes not
entirely rational cards whose interest
in the facts was marginal and who
occasionally found the distinction
between what was interesting to the
public and what was in the public
interest inconvenient
I also appeared before her ladyship in
the criminal division of the Court of
Appeal when I was Solicitor General the
courtesy with which she listened to my
submissions was not artificial but nor
was she held back by our friendship from
pulling me up if my arguments strayed
from the point at issue her focus on the
essential on the matters that need to be
decided will I know a sister in the
administrative work that lies ahead of
her just as it has enabled her to get to
the heart of cases she has had to try at
first instance or deal with on appeal
her judgments in the Court of Appeal and
in the High Court in areas inside and
outside the law of defamation repaid
careful study and display a humanity and
an exemplary care for justice my lord
for me and for all of us who have grown
up and developed as barristers at one
big court today is a bittersweet day we
are overjoyed and proud to be able to
congratulate one of our own Dame
Victoria on her appointment as president
of the Queen's Bench division that she
is the first woman to hold that office
is I suspect a matter of delightful
indifference but our great joy at her
success is tempered by the fact that our
chambers which has nurtured such a
superlative legal talent as her over it
long history closed its doors yesterday
after nearly 150 years we have all found
new homes at 5rb
at dotty Street at Ely place as in-house
lawyers at newspapers and listed firms
in retirement and in my case at four
pump court but as our little band
disperses we ask you to ask this one
indulgence that with the appointment of
Dame Victoria sharp as the new president
we can plant our standard on the
judicial heights and that on it we can
embroider her name as well as the names
of just some of her predecessors mentors
and contemporaries from chambers who
like her have helped to make the law of
England
Fraser Slade Duncan folks
Cusick Neel Hirst Houlihan Hartley
Briton
privity Rampton Edie Walker Shore
shields
Maloney and called Curt I don't thank
you now it's my great pleasure to
present you with letters patent
shorthand to you as you know as to most
people here I snatched them back so that
when you leave court your hands are free
to shake the hands of all your
colleagues I think the Registrar has a
duty to perform at this stage or the the
Senior Master it's probably my lord I
move that these proceedings be recorded
in the books at the Queen's Bench
division so be it